في زمن الازمات الاقتصاديه لن تكون في
مامن حتى وان كنت خلف مكتبك في العمل اكثر
من حرفيا يتقن مهنته اليدويه كانت جار او
حلاق او حتى عامل بناء
[موسيقى]
نحن لا نتحدث بالضروره عن دول الغرب حيث
موجات الاقالات في شركات التكنولوجيا
مثل الاردن حيث للمهن الحرفيه لا تتوافر
في غيرها مثل حريات ساعات العمل وعدم
احتياجها الى راس مال كبير وملائمتها لذوي
الدراسه المحدوده
[موسيقى]
والاهم من ذلك العوائد السريعه والمزيه
فبحسب الارقام يتراوح متوسط الاجور في
مهنه السباكه ما بين 620 دينارا شهريا
وتصل الى 920 دينار شهريا مقارنه بخريجه
هندسه يتقاضى 300 الى 400 دينار شهريا
[موسيقى]
وفي امريكا والدول المتقدمه نجد نوعا
مميزا من الرعايه لهذه المهن حيث اصبحت
السباكه في المرتبه الثانيه ضمن افضل مهن
المقاولات هناك وفي المرتبه الخامسه كافضل
مهنه دون تعليم اما من ناحيه الدخل فهي في
المرتبه التاسعه كافضل الوظيفه تضر دخلا
دون درجه علميه
في ما يصلوا اجر السباك من ساعات العمل
الاضافيه فقط الى 200 الف دولار سنويا
اضافه الى راتبه الثابت الذي يصل الى 90
الف دولار سنويا
[موسيقى]